yeah hello and welcome to this video
conceit it is the one that will get me
back over 2500 it's now probably not
mean I have to win first and down it
wouldn't get 10 points probably so
considered place a trump which I answer
with this c5 move
that's a sharp option and takes a little
time yeah white have some this is the
normal move let's say or the most
frequently played move maybe alright it
seems so it takes them a little bit by
surprise or maybe I don't know something
else is going on the one on his side he
puts it all the way back in the bishop
who well what am i doing against this he
six looks very very normal yeah I think
I'll do that
I mean it cannot go a three in this
position Queen h4 looks a little bit
like he when you didn't develop at all
so what's going on here yeah I can
probably just take that must be simple
and good yeah the Queen will probably go
all the way back I don't know go with it
I don't know why do you give me yet
another temple
I mean 96 is not a new violin pretty
much I'm unhappy to play what won't seem
so 96 now that's probably good I was
thinking uh maybe and something else you
so that's a very very weird way of
playing so I can care for now on at
night you for I don't know it doesn't
really need too much and it's just
careful not spend more time this will be
somewhat to my advantage
basically no matter what I play so
thinking too long as one way of getting
in trouble
you
yeah that runs in 2d 5d form
yeah that's true but there's still no
development going on so um what am I
doing here
94 and then 9 Bishop f5 no that would
actually blunder peace oh good so let's
go D 494 is it plays check
Wow he defended this this stuff at least
he thought that he's avoiding immediate
mate that it's it's really more than he
deserves but he did he did so what now
night I will see a problem I still have
a really good position I mean but with
Queens on white wouldn't have survived
move 20 probably okay so just not before
I guess yeah so how do how to polish
this stuff I mean really really polish
night before is the only move that prole
is putting up anything
can I take on c2 Knight f5 93 check King
D to check I don't know if that wins
doesn't look like it wins
fantastic development but maybe that
doesn't it's not enough 94 I can take on
c2 with the bishop yeah this is probably
a night jinx it's not doesn't look like
it win some you know it doesn't look
like it wins Knight takes Knight takes
f5 Knight e3 chick [ __ ] at the end
there's always night take c7 which is
really strange but it's what it is
and Bishop the ship c2 Knight takes
doesn't doesn't win it's a bit crazy but
it doesn't win vision things
I hope d8 I don't know maybe this is
right
maybe this is correct channel I have to
play move now I mean he cannot take the
night that's made III night take C -
should also I mean should win
maybe c3m okay so check he goes to D -
yeah kind of after but again there is no
wait
he's absolutely surviving this stuff ah
there is no justice well there is just
as I mean I I let him I allowed this
stuff it's just my fault not publishing
this stuff time warning okay you know
everyone comes instantly of course
Nadel winds you create everything
check check check check check
[Music]
light for fix on time no never never
test in their heart come on don't get me
started
then then never should be a move 20 in
this game I mean how how what is that
yeah okay so I probably yeah I know I
probably shouldn't give him the c5 porn
there with this crap Bishop f6 Queen c5
and really amazed that stockfish just
gives me a pawn and not more I mean
Queen D 5b 5b 3 this looks like beginner
chess I'm sorry but this is what it is
yeah and then somehow this is not losing
it even though I'm I'm castled and that
everything is Queen is all over the
place
amazing so these success what the engine
is giving
marcado okay and now he gets this this
in there and I mean I have enough for
the pawn and it's just too much
development but it's really remarkable
he's six
now I mean it's not bad I mean I played
Bishop e6 h 6 and so on
castling long I always have Queen a5 and
things yeah this is a cloudy but it was
almost funny and he couldn't find a win
here I mean maybe there isn't one and
the engine actually says there isn't one
I would really want to know why like
just to understand this game and in this
didn't work add you to c3 of it I mean I
saw that this is a move so this is
possible but well I bet I didn't see
yeah I just saw that he's got this but I
have this move okay so this is the clean
way of playing this this may be still
flooded for black so that is right there
and there's not more yeah this doesn't
lead to anything I can just take can
this this looks good at first but I mean
I have no move now and TLC 3 is good for
why - because this is just the game
until consolidates
it's really amazing also define was bad
I think this this is all fine and maybe
castling is more precise yeah that it's
possible this is a d6f 2:46 thing very
strange ok thanks for watching